[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the super bowl is in the books and no
better time to welcome everyone that's
right even the bengals even the rams to
draft season i'm the lead nfl draft
analyst here at bleacher report connor
rogers but i need a little help from my
friends before we do every single pick
of the first round because we want to
hear from you in the comments section
whether you love the pics whether you
hate the pics whether you have different
ideas and we're gonna have a lot of fun
with it today so i'm gonna bring in an
old friend here in greg ivory he's gonna
have your voices heard he's gonna have
the giveaways greg it is trap season it
is officially the nfl offseason how we
feeling how we living right now my man
connor feeling good living good and
feeling extra generous today so i need
everybody that is here in the comments
fill those comments up with takes uh and
i'm giving out hoodies man and i'm
hopefully giving out quite a few today
to some good takes so fill those
comments up y'all
you heard the man and you want to get on
greg's good side because he's got the
hoodies he's got the giveaways and he's
going to relay what you have to say to
me but let's waste no time let's get
into the pick and for the second year in
a row the jacksonville jaguars are back
on the clock with the number one overall
selection in the 2022 nfl draft and
we're gonna keep things simple and go
with evan neal in this spot the big
hulking athletic left tackle for alabama
played right tackle in 2020 and played
guard in 2019 so has positional
versatility for that jacksonville
jaguars offensive line this selection is
about helping trevor lawrence it's about
keeping him upright it's about
developing a run game that can open up
the vertical play action pass for the
former number one overall pick so he
needs help they already screwed this up
with hiring urban meyer they have not
put a good enough roster or offense
around trevor lawrence to begin with
evan neal is plug and play at multiple
positions he is going to dominate at the
nfl combine whether it's the
measurements whether it's the athletic
testing or the interviews obviously the
resume is there a winning resume as well
so they pass on some of the top flight
defenders in this draft and get an
anchor for their offensive line moving
on to number two the detroit lions a
pick that you're gonna see mocked pretty
much everywhere at this point aidan
hutchinson the star pass rusher from
michigan
went to the heisman ceremony that's the
kind of impactful year he had as a
defender up front in the trenches
whether it was against the run whether
it was the ability as a stand-up rusher
or the ability to play with his hand in
the dirt win on the outside counter on
the inside he has great short area
explosiveness to simply get after the
quarterback but i also like his ability
to convert speed to power the detroit
lions have done their homework already
on him i've heard tons of buzz that they
have obviously no problems taking him as
early as number two where they would be
thrilled to keep aiden hutchinson in the
state of michigan they took a couple
great defensive tackles last year
promising defensive tackles in last
year's draft now they get an edge
presence to play next to them to get
after the quarterback and most
importantly get a star potential player
on that roster so number three somebody
that was at the top of most mock drafts
early on whether it was the summer early
on in the season there's rumors of a
slide this is where that slide ends kvon
thibodeaux going to the houston texans
at number three overall and it's a
little bit of the same thought process
as the lions at number two where you are
looking to get a premium edge rusher up
front for your team because your roster
has so many holes that you need to take
somebody that can be the best player in
this entire draft but also plays a
premium position you watch the super
bowl you see how the games are won folks
you need a star quarterback and then you
need guys on the other side of the ball
that can make the star quarterback's day
a living hell and that's what k von
thibodeau has done in the pac-12 for
three years now right you look at it
freshman sophomore in junior year he's
gotten better throughout every year i
don't see a guy that's taking off plays
i do think he was playing through injury
this year the explosive testing is going
to be phenomenal and indie in just a
couple of weeks i think kayvon thibodeau
will remind people why he was mocked
first overall i can't see him escaping
the top five picks number four a team
that will pick twice in the top ten of
this draft the new york jets and there
is going to be a theme around the new
york jets this offseason that is get
zach wilson help we started this show
talking about how jacksonville needs to
get trevor lawrence the former number
one overall pick help the jets need to
get the former number two overall pick
help and zach wilson we're gonna go with
ikemekwanu the nasty nasty tackle from
nc state he is probably the best run
blocker in this entire draft he's not as
clean and pass protection as evan neal
went number one overall but his ability
to finish blocks as you see right there
in the run game it is tremendous it's as
good as it gets he has enough explosive
range to play in an outside zone scheme
which is what the new york jets are
going to run they want to get that
ground and pound going once again it's a
little similar to trevor lawrence they
want to get that ground and pound going
and build a vertical play action pass
game for zach wilson to throw the ball
down the field equano is a high floor
player that's plug and play i think he
can transition inside to guard if they
need him to if they like george fan and
mackay beckton starting at tackle next
year but obviously he has a great resume
playing left tackle for nc state this
year so number five to round out this
top five
the crosstown team the new york giants
are on the clock right now and they just
made an interesting higher on the
defensive side of the ball in wink
martindale they're coming from the
baltimore ravens where if you know
anything about wink martindale he is
going to bring pressure and he's going
to put a lot of pressure on his corners
to hold up in coverage and that brings
derek stingley into play here at number
five overall who had a standout freshman
season in 2019 was not as good but was
still a really good player in 2020 and
then missed most of this year due to
injury now it's time for derek stingley
to bounce back in this process he's got
great deep speed he's got great size at
one six two long arms the recovery speed
the ability to press in coverage and
hang with guys one on one in man
coverage that's what wink martindale is
going to ask for in this scheme they
need corners yes they pay to dorrie
jackson we know that but at the end of
the day it's got to be better and you
got to be thinking about the new regime
run by joe shane who's going to be our
franchise corner of the next five years
not the guys we paid or we didn't pay
dave gettleman paid in the last three so
the giants get somebody with really
superstar potential at the cornerback
position at number five and that's an
area where i think people need to start
looking for them number six the carolina
panthers this one has not been very
exciting because it just has not changed
over the mock drafts we've done here at
bleacher report but it's a safe pick in
charles cross the offensive tackle from
mississippi state
a two-year starter on the left side of
the offensive line a great athlete super
efficient in pass protection he's got
light feet he's very very smart and
tactical with his hands in his pass set
and he just doesn't get beat very often
and i think if you've watched the
panthers over the last couple years
their left tackle spot that's been the
issue is there has been no consistency
there so you can completely revamp and
upgrade that by landing charles cross
who's athletic enough to do really
anything you want in the run game but
most importantly is going to keep
whoever your quarterback of the future
is upright that's what they need and
he's in that big three of tackles in
this class and they're all gone evan
neal went number one to the jacksonville
jaguars ikem ekwano went number four to
the new york jets now charles cross the
final piece of that big three goes to
the panthers here this is a safe pick
for them this is a smart pick for them
trying to rebuild that roster all right
number seven here the giants are back on
the clock again they got derek stingley
doing a favor from lake martindale now
they're going to look at that offensive
line that has to get better and they're
going to take tyler linderbaum the best
center i've ever evaluated in my time of
doing this
he is an incredible prospect at the
position yes centers are not valued
enough to go in the top five they're
usually not valued enough to go in the
top ten for the giants here this is a
massive need they need to get better on
the offensive line andrew thomas did get
better last year so you feel good about
your left side i think they explore
maybe right tackles with that first pick
in this draft but in this scenario they
get a plug-and-play pro bowl level level
player and tyler linderbaum that can
give some room for saquon barkley can
give daniel jones a chance and really
has that tough guy mentality that
leadership element they've been missing
in the trenches on the offensive side of
the ball since they were in the super
bowl that's how long it's been for the
giants with their uh struggles in the
trenches so we've had the giants picked
twice in the top seven we've had some
mega picks at the top with hutchinson
and thibodeau gone jacksonville and the
jets trying to get help for their young
quarterbacks as well i think it's a
great time to check in with greg because
the comments are jumping right now or at
least that's what i hear greg what are
they saying right now what are they mad
about what do they like what are they
connor
giants fans are not happy with your
first pick brother they're in the
comments saying uh they don't think that
they need a cornerback with the first
pick i got
t-gib t-gibb says zero percent the
giants take a corner i also got oh no in
the comments saying it is a great pick
at that spot but he doesn't know if the
giants will draft stingley there uh
connor they're all over the place in the
comments the giants fans are up in arms
but i got a question i want to know is
the giants gonna address the quarterback
situation
in new york
or are they gonna address the offensive
line situation in new york to help out
with the quarterback daniel jones
i think it's the latter greg and it's a
great question i think when you listen
to ownership they've stood by daniel
jones and have publicly admitted that
they have failed him and whether that's
the right or wrong decision i think he
gets this season to with a better
supporting cast like tyler linderbaum
added there to prove himself and if it
doesn't work out you have new hires in
brian davil and joe shane that can sit
there and go we have plenty of time if
we fail with daniel jones in year one or
we don't see him take the proper steps
that we need to see then we can move on
i know everybody love they're enamored
with the trade for russell wilson or
some kind of veteran presence this is
not the quarterback class that you want
to get in the mix for if you're the new
york giants i'd rather kick that cam
down the road with a better group in
2023 so the theme of my draft was just
get good football players i understand
the the uh being upset about stingley i
just think with the defensive
coordinator hired that's an area that is
being overlooked but if the giants took
charles cross there at five or george
karloftis i would not be surprised at
all so this is a different scenario than
what we presented in the last two mock
drafts but i think there will be a
mission to make that offensive line
better for daniel jones for saquon
barkley and that's the lindebon pick
yes sir and i need everybody and i mean
everybody to fill those comments up with
takes giving away hoodies
giving away hoodies i am giving away
hoodies connor
greg you are always in a given mood
let's keep this mock draft going in the
giving spirit we are on the clock at
number eight with the atlanta falcons
and they are going to take the best
player available in this draft they did
that last year instead of opting for a
quarterback when they took kyle pitts
now they're gonna do it at eight here on
the other side of the ball and kyle
hamilton from notre dame the safety that
is really a do-it-all defensive player
he can play up high he can play too high
single high he can play quarters
coverage he can come down to the box
great tackler very physical player as
you see there he's also got the range to
be a ball-hawking safety in the back end
to get interceptions and break up passes
i do think you can come down in the slot
and match up with tight ends which is
something that uh you need in this day
and age with the way the tight ends are
worked up the seam vertically
on modern offenses so i look at kyle
hamilton one of the best prospects in
this entire draft and the falcons are in
a mold right now where they have a young
regime there since they moved on from
thomas to mitrop where they just want to
build out the best possible roster in
the last couple years of matt ryan's
career there and once again i just don't
think there's a quarterback that they
would value in this spot to sit behind
matt ryan they'd rather get a high floor
player in hamilton's case he's not just
high floor greg he is high ceiling so
the falcons end up with one of the top
overall talents in this draft all the
way in the eighth pick now at number
nine we are going to talk quarterback
and this one comes with a disclaimer as
the denver broncos are on the clock i
think ultimately the broncos will be in
the veteran quarterback market their
dream scenario is to get aaron rodgers
from green bay
it feels unlikely as much as that match
makes so much sense so when you look at
the broncos let's say they can't get
rogers let's say they can't get russ
that they're not happy with how the
veteran market played out then they have
to look at this draft to get better and
i'm going to go with malik willis the
quarterback from liberty who was
phenomenal at the senior ball
coming off the board here in the top 10
picks and with malik willis this is a
swing for upside pick he is mobile he
has a big time arm yes there will be a
developmental curve there whether it is
timing whether it is seeing the field
which is a common theme for every young
quarterback in this entire trap but
getting the ball out on time and
avoiding those delayed turnovers but
there's just too much talent here from
malik willis where his athleticism can
carry him while he continues to develop
the rest of his game this is a great
offense for him to walk into they have
one of the best young running backs in
the league and javonte williams they
have a jump ball targeting cortland
sutton they have a separator and jerry
judy and then they kind of have a number
three do-it-all threat in tim patrick so
they have two tight ends that can catch
the ball as well i look at the broncos
and just think they can afford to go
into the year maybe with a veteran that
starts out the season while malik willis
sits for a little bit but at some point
you've got to get him in the game he can
impact your run game and he can push the
ball down the field so the broncos their
first choice will be to go after a
veteran quarterback that's no surprise
but if all else fails they have to take
the swing here and malik willis is the
guy that i would take for them all right
number ten to round out this top ten the
new york jets are back on the clock
we've got the giants picked twice now
we'll have the jets picked for a second
time and the theme of getting zach
wilson helped continues on the trail and
berks at number 10 overall so he's the
first wide receiver to come off the
board in this draft and i think
everybody is going to get on board with
that after the nfl combine berks is six
foot two he's about 225 230 pounds i
think he's gonna run at least a four
four forty so you're talking about
legitimate vertical deep speed he's a
menace with the ball in his hands he's a
menace without the ball in his hands as
you see him go up and win in contested
catch situations and he catches
everything and that was a problem for
the new york jets this year despite
struggles you know maybe at times with
the young quarterback and zach wilson
and their defense
their skill players just dropped the
ball way too many times when they were
schemed open and trailing burks will not
be doing that so for the jets here they
had their choice of drake london garrett
wilson or traelyn burks as much as i
love garrett wilson in this spot as well
they have a separator they took last
year and elijah moore that they feel
good about and they paid one in corey
davis now you get a different player for
that offense and trailing burke so the
last three picks we had kyle hamilton go
to the falcons malik willis our first
quarterback of the draft come off the
board of the broncos and the jets use
their second pick in the top ten on
treylin burks to get zach wilson even
more help so greg it's time for a
check-in i don't want you over there
collecting dust i need you live and
ready and i know the vibes are good
right now over there so let me know
because we have angry fans we have happy
fans you knew you and i'm i'm in the
tri-state so i got to be careful with
the new yorker how they feeling right
now
connor fans are up and down up and down
but we also have fans that are aligning
with you i have new york jets 9180 says
connor is gonna go with berks or wilson
for the jets here and connor you went
with my guy burke's so shout out to 91
uh jets you are walking away with the br
gridiron hoodie for your take appreciate
that i also got breezy kid says they
need a pass rusher the jet should take a
pass rusher at 10. um
kade jb also is in the comments says why
berks instead of defense conor and i
wanted to talk about that my question is
the jets struggled tremendously on
defense they got a defensive minded
coach in robert sala
so do they address the defensive side of
the ball through the draft or through
free agency because that's a big part
that they need to address this upcoming
offseason
i think you nailed it greg i think it's
that they can buy a defense right and
then they can draft an offense and what
i mean by that is or why that's the
strategy is the jets defense with how
abysmal it was last year can not really
wait for guys to develop this year they
have to go by proven starters that are
25 26 27 maybe even 28 years old at
times guys that come in and will pick up
the system and can start from day one
and have an impact for you and they have
i think top five cap space in the league
as it stands right now could even be top
three when it all shakes out after cuts
so when you look at it like that they
can go buy the veterans that they want
for the defensive side of the ball and
when you draft the young offensive
players with the rookie wage scale that
means you know they're going to be with
zach wilson for at least the next five
years so it gives you a foundation for
your quarterback to build chemistry and
grow with them but the jets fans know me
well i knew they would know that burke's
pick and i can't argue there is a pass
rusher on the board here that you can
make an argument for in george karloftis
that i think would be a really really
good pick it's not going to be very long
though before we hear his name called
yes sir yes sir fill those comments up
guys make sure you guys fill those
comments up
all right greg's all over the ipad he's
got the comments going he's going to
relay your messages to me and if he
likes them like we've seen you're going
to walk away with the br gird iron
hoodie pretty good deal all right moving
on out of the top 10 number 11 another
quarterback pick here as the commanders
are on the clock yes i said at the
washington
commanders they're going with matt
corral the underclassmen of the early
declaration quarterback of this class he
was not at the senior ball the question
is will he be healthy enough to go
through a full workout after suffering
an injury in their bowl game and you see
with corral there very athletic a good
rhythm thrower he's got the ability to
push the ball down the field i don't
think he's in the ear of the
quarterbacks we saw last year with
lawrence wilson fields lance and even
mack jones but he's somebody that can
come in and give an upgrade to this
washington offense where they have not
been able to find that guy and i think
it makes you kind of give the same
disclaimer that we did with denver where
they are going to explore the veteran
market they're going to see who they can
get to come play for them what kind of
capital they have the 11th overall pick
is a good trade asset to get a veteran
quarterback instead and maybe if they
don't trade the 11th pick but they do
get a veteran quarterback they can use
this to help that offense as well so
matt corral comes off the board at pick
11. i think this pick will be very
interesting to see how it plays out when
we do a post-free agency mock draft all
right moving on pick number 12 and i
already hinted at this guy coming off
the board it is george karloff is from
purdue going to the minnesota vikings
danielle hunter has struggled with
injuries as great of a player as he is
and even when hunter is on the field you
still need another pass rusher across
from him carlatus is a powerful
short area explosiveness in terms of
straight line now his short area change
of direction gonna be a little bit of an
issue with him that's something i have a
question about going into the combine
but his effort his hands his raw power
it jumps out and you see it right there
he never gives up on a play and i think
his best football is ahead of him being
born in greece picking up the sport
later in life there is a big ceiling
there to unlock with george karloftis
and minnesota is never going to be shy
about drafting a pass rusher with all
traits in the world so
13th pick on the board right now and it
is the cleveland browns and we know dang
well that they need a wide receiver and
in this scenario the board breaks
perfectly for them because the only one
gone is traelyn burks now they keep
garrett wilson in the state of ohio the
former buckeye going to the browns he
reminds me of calvin ridley just an
excellent separator can create after the
catch as you see there
the short area change of direction is
not a problem with him the tracking the
concentration to play the football in
the air is phenomenal so when you look
at garrett wilson i actually think he's
the most plug and play ready wide
receiver in this draft that's what the
browns know they need for baker mayfield
they got to get it right to get him a
number one target i think wilson can
come in catch 80 passes for a thousand
yards and eight to ten touchdowns right
away so this is maybe the biggest
no-brainer of the entire mock draft so
far garrett wilson goes to the cleveland
browns at 13. all right
brown's fans are always loud so i think
we gotta do a little checking greg what
do we got going on right now from the
dog pound over there
hey connor i got osu versus the world oh
seven says browns need garrett wilson at
13. great route running amazing high
point can thrive in the wide receiver
spot he's on the save wavelength as you
connor so shout out to you uh andy you
are walking away with a br gridiron
hoodie um
connor i got a question regarding the
browns they're running backs they've
been quite they've been injured quite
often in the last two seasons
do you think they addressed that in this
year's draft i know i know they got
kareem hunt i know they got they got
star running backs there but do they
address that in this
offseason
yeah i think it's a fair question when
you're looking at later day two day
three of the draft right you have nick
chubb who's a superstar you have kareem
hunt who is on a short-term deal and can
always be a trade asset for you so you
feel good about your frontline carries
but you know and even to ernest johnson
somebody that came in and picked up a
you know a valuable role for them when
the opportunity presented itself so when
i look at the browns they're looking
more in the categories of the brian
robinson jr right the tyler algiers from
byu abram smith from baylor guys that
are going to go in the fourth fifth and
sixth round of the draft that can come
in and be an rb three for the browns and
be the long-term backup from nick chubb
of the future
got you got you everybody fill those
comments up make sure you guys keep
giving us those good takes because i'm
still giving away those br grid iron
hoodies
all right picking up the pace here we
are at number 14 with the baltimore
ravens and the second cornerback is
coming off the board he is my top corner
in this draft and that is sauce gardner
from cincinnati so we're still talking
about ohio but now we're making sauce
gardener go to baltimore
i just love the way this guy plays
whether it's the physicality and man
coverage whether it's the ability to
come downhill and make a tackle as a run
stopper or as a blitzer he has the best
tape of any corner in this entire draft
i think he has the best mentality of any
corner in this entire trap i love sauce
gardener's confidence uh his ability to
get it done on any stage when you watch
him play against alabama he did not look
like he was missing steph he looked like
those guys are not going to give him a
problem those are the type of players
he's going to see at the nfl level so
sauce gardener to the ravens i still
think they need some corner help with
all the injuries they dealt with at the
position last year 15 we got the eagles
on the clock back to back 15 and 16.
number 15. we're gonna go with devin
lloyd my top linebacker in this trap he
comes from utah a three-down player can
run and chase can come downhill can
blitz can play the pass he can run and
cover his speed his size he checks every
single box devin lloyd you see the
acceleration with that interception
right there playmaker is the name of his
game you just look at the eagles right
now this is the presence they've been
missing in the middle of their defense
for a couple years i know eagles fans
might look at it and go with howie we
will never draft the linebacker this
early sometimes you've got to change to
get better and sometimes you've got to
accept that this can be a little bit
different you have three picks this is
the year to do it i love devin lloyd's
game he can come in and be a leader for
the middle of that defense the second
pick for the eagles we're going to go
with jameson williams here and this is a
little bit of a draft and stash pick
because of the injury he suffered in the
college football playoff but the eagles
wide receiver corpse needs deep speed
yes you've got devonte smith and he's
going to be a really good player for a
long time you've got a great run game
but how do you make a great run game
better besides trapping offensive line
you stretch the field the vertical
playmaker jamison williams that knee
should check out at the combine he will
probably be good to go early on in the
season as long as his rehab goes
smoothly there is no faster receiving
threat in the strap than jameson
williams probably would have ran a sub
4-3 if he did not get hurt i think this
is one of those picks for the eagles
where at the time you might be
disappointed that he's not going to be
on the field in training camp right away
and then you look a year or two later
from now and you go wow we got to steal
because we decided to be patient so i
think he fits their offensive needs like
a glove with no trailing berks and no
garrett wilson on the board so the
eagles make out at 15 and 16 with devin
lloyd jameson williams and they will be
back on the clock in just a little bit
so eagles fans get ready to jump off in
that comment section let me know how you
feel all right 17 the los angeles
chargers they've been a popular pick for
defensive line but we're going to look
at some a different scenario here and go
with trent mcduffie a west coast corner
staying on the west coast for the la
chargers here
mcduffie much like sauce gardener just
has tremendous film now he's not going
to pass the measurable measurables test
that stingley does he's not going to
come in at over six feet tall he's not
going to come in and intercept you know
eight passes for you anything like that
he is just a natural at the position
great instincts great form tackling
really good sideline to sideline speed
where he's ready to come in and start
for you and the chargers secondary they
need that they need a guy of the future
that can play on the outside and play on
the inside i love mcduffie's versatility
i love his range and i love his attitude
and the chargers right now they need a
little help on that defensive side of
the ball see how free agency shakes out
for them what they're going to do to
continue justin herbert's development
but right now we're going to go corner
because i think they can get that
interior defensive line help on day two
of the draft instead of reaching here so
new orleans saints a lot of change for
them over the recent years they are on
the clock at 18. they got an old but new
coach now and dennis allen taking over
for sean payton we don't know what their
future quarterback situation looks like
but we do know they're gonna need wide
receiver help and we don't know what the
future for mike thomas looks like there
so we're gonna go with drake london
maybe the best contested catch threat in
this entire draft one of the best
contested catch threats that i've seen
in recent years with drake london now he
really reminds me of cortland sutton
from a couple years ago a guy that you
throw to even when he's not open and
that can help no matter who the
quarterback is taysom hill jameis
winston we don't know but what we do
know is both of those guys are gonna
need all the help they can get and you
see london's ability to box out smaller
defensive backs the catch radius is you
know
right there it's a 99 it's as good as it
gets and the tracking but i also like
what he can do with the ball in his
hands after the catch just because he's
not as sudden or twitchy a bigger guy at
six foot five doesn't mean that he can't
come in and have an instant impact so
the saints get that long needed wide
receiver help
number 19 the eagles i promise you
they'd be back on the clock the wait was
not long we're going with jermaine
johnson standout pass rusher from
florida state the transfer from georgia
he's had a hell of a road going last
chance u to georgia the florida state to
being a senior bowl superstar jermaine
johnson has been maybe the breakout
prospect of this year's draft when you
look at the pass rushing ability he's
got length he's got power he can win the
corner he can counter inside and the
effort is just phenomenal as you see the
quarterback hit there to force an
interception so jermaine johnson that
motor always runs hot he's got a full
toolbox of pass rushing ability tools
moves to win right away and i think his
reading react against the run will get
him on the field really early so when
you look at the eagles hall right there
they get devin lloyd from the middle of
their defense they get jermaine johnson
for the front of their defense and then
they get jameson williams to give them
vertical speed on offense greg time for
a check-in yes sir
do those eagles fans want to kill me
right now or are they walking away real
happy with this haul of three prospects
connor the eagles fans are up and down
but i do want to mention shout out to
the ravens fans because the sauce
gardener pick had the comments jumping
like no other drew evans says ravens
wanted that sauce shout out to you drew
b douglas six says whoever gets sauce
gardener at this point is walking away
lucky shout out to you b douglas you are
walking away with a br gridiron hoodie
but connor i'm not forgetting about
these eagles fans because they are also
in the comments i got i never resurfaced
anything says the eagles have three
picks in the middle of a top
heavy defensive in class should they
move up or fill other needs connor i
guess that is my question to you and
that is my man i need resurface question
to you
they want to know do they feel other
needs or should they go heavy at
defensive end
it's a great question because the man
has done his research this is a good
edge class but i think when you look at
it it's still in tears greg it's aiden
hutchinson and k-von thibodeau at the
top then you have this group in the
middle that'll consist of george
karloftis jermaine johnson and maybe
david ojabo and they're all different in
their own way if i'm an eagles fan i
don't want to miss out on that second
tier i don't want to get too cute with
it and wait too long so for the eagles
there play it safe get your defensive
help if you want to trade one of those
back-to-back picks and move down and get
a wide receiver later or get a
linebacker later maybe devin lloyd is
the most movable pick here but edge is
something i would never ever wait on
when you look into the stats it tells
you that basically after the first round
edge rushers do not hit very often it's
one of the most consistent draft trends
so i love the question it's a really
good one we know howie likes to move up
and down the board so i think the eagles
will look into that but i would not pass
on jermaine johnson at 19.
a d-boy 22 connor he's rocking with you
he said that's a perfect pick up for the
eagles so uh shout out to you d-boy 22
you're walking away with a br gridiron
hoodie but everybody continue to fill
those comments up i'm still got some
hoodies to give away
all right we're gonna check back in with
greg in just a little bit and give you a
chance to win some more hoodies get your
thoughts heard we're gonna keep the
clock moving right now the pittsburgh
steelers are on the clock with 20
overall and they are going quarterback
and they are going with the local guy in
the pit standout in kenny pickett and i
think he is the
most
high floor quarterback of this trap
whether it's the ball placement the
accuracy uh the ability to go through
his progressions and get rid of the ball
or the ability to make a play outside of
the pocket i think kenny pickett could
come in and have some instant success
with naji harris there yes their
offensive line needs help and that's
something they're going to have to
address in free agency the trade market
and even the draft in this situation but
he's going to be able to get the ball to
deonte johnson and chase claypool and
pat friarmuth they have an array of
weapons there in pittsburgh that would
really really flourish i think with
kenny pickett i think when he's maxed
out he's a derek carr level player and
that might not excite a lot of people
but i don't think the steelers need more
than that with the roster they have
built the offensive line just needs a
couple tweaks here and there so can he
pick it at 20. he doesn't have the
ceiling of a matt corral or malik willis
but he has a higher floor and a more pro
ready skill set that can come in and
play right away for the steelers all
right 21 the patriots are on the clock
and i am looking all over at wide
receiver for the new england patriots
i'm going with chris salabe from ohio
state somebody that's gotten done over a
long stretch of time while wearing a
buckeyes uniform i think he would have
been a top 40 pick if he had declared
last year instead he opted to go back to
school had another great season playing
with cj stroud and he goes 21 here to
new england where somebody that the ball
tracking vertically down the field the
hands the ability to separate it's not
that different from his teammate garrett
wilson i don't think he's going to be as
short area explosive but he might have a
little bit more vertical juice when you
look at a lobby he's gotten it done on
special teams he's gotten it done on the
offense in the short area the
intermediate and the vertical game
when you look at new england right now
they went out and spent a lot of money
on offense last year but they still need
a number one wide receiver for mack
jones so they go with chris a lobby in
this spot moving on to the raiders and
sticking with wide receiver they need
speed right there's no doubt about that
this is a roster now that you look at it
and they do not have a vertical threat
and that's been a theme of this mock
trap you need guys that went down the
field we're going with johan dobson here
from penn state somebody that i think
could run in the four threes i think has
great concentration very explosive after
the catch with the ball in his hands and
for the raiders now you've built out an
offense that is going to be coached by
josh mcdaniels run by derek carr where
you have darren waller and foster moreau
in your two tight end sets you have
hunter renfo renfro that can win in the
slot you have brian edwards that can be
that outside short intermediate target
what are you missing you're missing the
rocket right you're missing jahan datsun
that can win down the field open up the
run game stretch the field and also
create plays for the quarterback on
screens on pitch passes on all those
short area drags and slants so i love
jahan dots and the raiders i think
that's a seamless fit when you look at
what they're going to want to do under
mcdaniels all right
arizona cardinals on the clock now we've
heard plenty of rumors and buzz this
week that kylo murray is not thrilled
with what they've built over there
now with that being said i still think
they need to look on the defensive side
of the ball and go corner here roger
mccreary one of the best players
available at 23 in the spot an outside
corner that just had a phenomenal year
very sticky in coverage stays in the hip
pocket and make a play on the football
can come up and really lay a big hit you
see how he's used as a blitzer you see
the ability to go find the ball in the
air but creery is
really somebody that showed at the
senior ball he is ready to come in and
play right away this isn't a damon
arnett
ceiling pick this isn't a roll of dice
to say can we get a starter that has
gotten it done at the highest level in
the sec and can start for us on the
outside even got inside looks at the
senior goal which i think is going to
help his long-term perspective so for
arizona right here in this spot
they need to get younger at corner they
need to get better at corner mccreary is
almost you know is the next guy up in a
very good corner class and here's his
name called in the first round all right
24 the dallas cowboys cowboys fans
nothing they love more than mock drafts
i feel like they have some of the
loudest voices we're going to take a
safe selection here and solve that
revolving door at left guard with kenyan
green from texas a m now he came into
this year he started at left tackle he's
played all four spots on the offensive
line the only thing he hasn't played is
center so you've seen him at left tackle
you've seen him at left guard you've
seen him at both spots on the right side
and i think he's a long-term guard in
the future because of his run blocking
because of his ability you know at times
in pass pro where he does not have the
necessary quickness to protect the
outside but he can play it on the inside
and survive that way because his anchor
strength is truly truly special so for
the cowboys there you look at kenyan
green maybe you can develop him long
term as a tackle it's kind of like
ikemekwano that went to four for the
jets where might start out a guard and
then you move them to tackle for the
future i think green can be that player
for the cowboys but they are a win-now
team and they get a win now player to
start for them on the inside that would
be an excellent excellent run blocking
addition so i've had a couple picks come
off the board here can he pick it to the
steelers cursed lobby to the patriots
johann dotson to the raiders roger
mccreery to the cardinals and then
canyon green to the cowboys to shore up
a little bit of an aging offensive line
greg i said it earlier those cowboys
fans are always jumping in the comments
now i think they are a smart fan base
that understands a safe pick how are
they feeling right now
at connor they're on your side brother i
got bounce out sean great pick for the
cowboys great pick for the cowboys uh
trevor doyle soon as you said uh
the pic they said let's go soon you said
kenyon green they said let's go also
bounce out sean says kg with a lot of
exclamation points so the cowboy fans
are hyped also got cowboy spurs says
cowboys love it need to build up on the
big boys uh shout out to you cowboy
spurs i'm giving you a br grid iron
hoodie also want to talk about the
steelers because
they
were in the comments as well uh t groves
90 says pickett feels like a steeler
shout out to you hedge med says pick it
to the steelers it's a perfect pit
connor so the vibes are flowing the
vibes are flowing with you also raiders
you mentioned them earlier sosa manglo
says raider nation i think that is a
great pick they love the wide receiver
pick uh mr mcchompi says datsun would be
a great fit to help spread that offense
connor so the vibes are going in the
comments the vibes are going we're
getting good juju uh but i need
everybody to continue to fill those
comments up because
i still got some hoodies to give away
greg still got some movie hoodies
everybody could take a lesson from the
cowboys steelers and raiders fans
they're feeling real good right now
let's make some dreams come true for
everyone else 25 the buffalo bills are
on the clock and i can't believe this
guy made it this far but just didn't
find the right home for him yet we're
going david jabo from michigan they've
played across from aidan hutchinson this
year another one-year breakout player
that is a speed rusher on the outside he
is a stand-up speed rusher that he's
gonna have to put more weight on his
lower half to play with his hand in the
dirt and contain the run but you see the
explosive nature to get into the pocket
and play the football or play the
quarterback you can get the strip sack
we've seen a spin move from him we've
seen the outside ghost move where he can
dip that shoulder and go untouched so a
jabbo he's going to have a big time nfl
combine i think everybody and you see
the spin right there i think everybody
at michigan was a little surprised that
he left school early but i think he's
going to go in the first round because
of it the bills are a team that
you know they're going to run into joe
burrow and patrick mahomes for the long
term future and and what you got to do
is you got to get players that can
affect those guys timing in the pocket
and move them off structure so ojabo is
that guy for the bills and i know last
year they took gregory rousseau i know
they've addressed this situation uh but
they are in a situation where they still
need more edge rush help until they get
it right and a jabbo can be a versatile
presence for them at edge pass rush so
moving on to another big time contender
this year the number one seed from the
afc the tennessee titans they got to get
back to what they do best and that's
running the ball with derek henry so
we're gonna go with zion johnson here
from boston college who has played left
guard in 2019 left tackle in 2020 and
then left guard again in 2021 he worked
out at center at times at the senior
bowl but i love his long-term outlook at
guard and the titans love the
versatility from their offensive line
where can zion play tackle in a pinch
absolutely can he be an upper level
player inside at guard absolutely i
think that's where his long-term home is
i think when you look at how thick he's
built the anchor strength the grip
strength with the hands to move guys to
redirect defensive linemen to gear
derrick henry to the second level of the
field get that train rolling down the
tracks that's how you do it right there
so when you
so when you look at it for the titans
right there
this is what they are this is their
identity you know with the ryan
tannehill contract
they can't obviously move on from that
deal it's too hard from them so
zion johnson right here goes to the
titans i think one of the better value
picks one of the safer picks in this
draft he's got three years of tape to
prove that all right 27
looking at high floor picks and man it
doesn't get much better than this we're
going with the big man jordan davis from
georgia going to the bucks this is a
defensive line that is a very good unit
but i do think they are slowly starting
to show their age or will show their age
in the long run so jordan davis yes he
didn't play all the snaps for georgia
that conditioning at that size he's
let's keep in mind he is a mammoth he's
not going to be on the field every three
down todd bowles is going to rotate that
front he's going to use a deep rotation
defensive lineman jordan davis is the
the biggest the beefiest interior run
stopper in this draft i think he's got
some ability to get the quarterback if
you give him a chance with the way he
can push the pocket and that'll open the
door for their edge rushers whether it's
jpp whether it's last year's first round
pick and joe trion so i love jordan
davis in the spot the bucks have some
questions at quarterback that they have
to answer but i think we'll have a
better idea of that after the free
agency period unless tom brady surprises
us and comes back from retirement
already all right moving on and sticking
with the trenches we're looking at the
green bay packers at 28. they're gonna
get some offensive line help as well
when you look at trevor penning coming
from northern iowa he played left tackle
for them this year and when you look at
this he's somebody that can probably
slide inside the guard if he can improve
that lower body strength and once again
continue to build a strong anchor
penning is a nasty tough run blocker
green bay loves that kind of player they
want to win the game in the trenches and
then open things up for aaron rodgers so
the packers they've dealt with some
aging and injuries on that offensive
line they have one of the best offensive
linemen uh in the nfl out of the young
guys in elgin jenkins who they've moved
all across the way but they still need
more they still need to get younger with
this group and penning is that guy that
can come in and do that for them as this
offensive line board starts to dwindle
he's one of the last big names left on
the board so
keeping with the offensive line theme
miami dolphins are on the clock and they
have not gotten this position right
under chris greer it's been really at
this point a disaster for them so they
have to keep taking their swings they
have to rely on their new head coach
mike mcdaniel uh to help with the
evaluations and get this right and there
aren't many better run block finishers
in this trap and darion canard from
kentucky they're starting right tackle
another player like penning that i think
can he play right tackle at the next
level probably is he best suited for
guard yet probably so for the dolphins
that's a side of their offensive line
that undoubtedly needs help when you
look at canard we know under mcdaniel
they are going to run run run to protect
tua that's what they've done in san
francisco for jimmy g you're going to
send mcdaniel has been the guy to build
that run game in san francisco under
kyle shanahan now he's taking that to
miami this has to be an offensive line
pick and you're in a scenario where you
cannot wait because they are all coming
off the board so
now we'll take a little break from the
offensive line as the kansas city chiefs
are on the clock they need corners and
you saw this in the playoffs after what
josh allen did to them they need cover
corners and this is a new name in the
mock draft series we've done here at
bleacher report tyler gordon from
washington he's got the length he's got
the speed you see it right there the
ability to come downhill and break up a
pass going over the top but can you turn
your hips and run vertically down the
field and find the football yeah he
can't and you see the body control the
rare athleticism that he has at the
position this guy is built like an
outside wide receiver playing cornerback
and his physicality once again that deep
speed it kind of reminds you a little
bit of antonio camardi in that spot so i
look at kyler gordon and think after the
combine he's going to shoot up boards
because he's going to test really well
everybody likes the look of him and how
he projects to playing on the outside
and that's exactly what the chiefs
needed in the spot they rebuilt their
offensive line last year i think they
can get another wide receiver maybe in
free agency or a veteran trade market
and instead they can get younger on the
defensive side of the ball with kyler
gordon at number 30 overall so 31
cincinnati bengals there's no surprise
here everybody knows they got to get
offensive line help the problem is a lot
of them are off the board so they are
down to one of the last guys that i can
sell as a first round pick and bernard
ryman another one of these guys you know
we talked about it with george karloftis
coming over from greece when you look at
ryman he started playing football late
in his later on in his life he actually
has converted from tight end to
offensive line he's done that seamlessly
as he watched left tackle tape right
here his ability to drive block in the
run game is going to help the bengals
with joe burrow and joe mixon and he
would be an upgrade in pass protection
but he's got work to do i think there's
times where the outside speed rushers
beat that shoulder and able to turn the
corner and beat him inside so that's an
area where he needs to improve but when
you are picking 31st overall in the
draft you are not getting perfect
players you are getting players that
need to be coached up but the bengals
have no choice here they have to go
offensive line and ryman you can sell as
a late first round pick all right to
wrap this up before we check in with
greg because we want to hear from you
with your comments your questions and we
want to give you some hoodies come on we
got to do that if you stuck around this
long you deserve a shot at a br gird
iron hoodie all right the detroit lions
are on the clock because the rams
obviously traded this pick to get matt
stafford i think that worked out pretty
well for them as they are currently
celebrating the super bowl right now
while we are at work the detroit lions
are on the clock and we're gonna go into
kobe dean i could not let him fall out
of round one in the scenario yes he's
undersized he's about six foot 225
pounds he does not play like it he's a
force in the middle of the field he's a
leader he's one of the best blitzers in
this draft his instincts the ability to
sniff out screens or as you see right
there with the pick six he reads
everything so well before the snap he is
the heart and soul of that georgia
defense so i love nikobi dean the lions
once again you got aidan hutchinson
early on impact pass rusher now you got
a impact you know middle of the field
player in the kobe dean they are trying
to revitalize this roster and get right
i think they had a good draft last year
and i don't think they're going to rush
into a quarterback in this spot i think
they're going to be comfortable as you
know as maybe as disappointed is to roll
with jared goff one more year i think in
this spot you don't just take a
quarterback to take one you want to take
talent and the kobe dean i think he's
going to be a top 20 player for me the
lions get him at 32. all right let's
bring greg in here right now because
we've had our longest run of pick since
we started the show 25 david a job out
of the bills 26 zion johnson to the
titans uh 27 jordan davis to the bucks
beef up their interior defensive line 28
trevor pennington the packers helped
their offensive line same with the
dolphins at 29 going with darion canard
chiefs take kyler gordon the corner from
washington at 30. bernard ryman the
offensive lineman from central michigan
going to the bengals nekobi dean to the
lions at 32 at linebacker greg this is a
lot right here is anything sticking out
to you right now with the comments
connor that was that was a lot and and
the comments was jumping brother the
comments were jumping starting off with
the bills they love the ojabo pick i got
the fifth edition says ojabo and buffalo
would be scary uh shout out to you uh
dylan dylan genn says ojabo will be a
cheat code if he failed to the bills
shout out to you the titans was also in
the comments uh they were talking they
loved the zion johnson pick i got m kent
93 says zion johnson is a stud that's a
great pick for the titans mkhit 93 you
are walking away with a br gridiron
hoodie i also also got love from the
bucks fans connor the bucks fans were in
the comments showing your pick love uh
jets forms says jordan davis and vida
veil would be a wall in tampa and i
agree with that
shan reddy was also in the comments and
said jordan javis via veda equals zero
rushing yards for opposing offenses so
they were rocking with that pick uh that
jordan davis pick and buff uh in the
buccaneers the chiefs the chiefs uh
chiefs unikc
says love the gordon pick chiefs needs
someone to lock up half the field uh
they are rocking with you lions also
says detroit needs a wide receiver kg
state
connor
the comments was loving your pigs bro
the comments was loving your picks but i
got one from matt columbia he says what
can the bengals give up to get to 10 to
get to the 10th spot to really solidify
that offensive line for joe burrow i
think he's talking about trades connor
he's talking about trades potential
trades we didn't really talk trades that
much do you see any potential trades
going down in this first round well
number one i love the comment i love
thinking aggressive when your team can
win a super bowl and your team the
cincinnati bengals have shown that if
you can make it to a super bowl and
upset a lot of teams along the process
you can win one you're close so i like
the aggressive nature now to get from 31
to 10 greg that's gonna cost you right
it's the cost of doing business where
i think you're gonna have to look to
other drafts i think it's gonna cost you
31 and i think it would cost you next
year's first rounder to go up to 10 but
that price is worth it if one of the big
three fall right evan neal is not going
to be there i don't think that quantum
is going to be there can charles cross
fall to 10 there's a really good chance
what if the panthers go quarterback
instead so if you can get a franchise
offensive lineman like a charles cross
or you can go the budget route you go up
from 31 and instead you go into the
early 20s instead and you walk away with
a darion canard kind of player instead
rather than taking a chance on somebody
that in my opinion is a little bit more
raw in bernard ryman so i love the
thought process it's going to be a
little pricey there's different ways to
maneuver around the board and greg after
you're reading those comments you notice
one theme and i get it i root for a bad
football team the fans of the winning
teams are happier with their draft the
vibes are a little better everybody's
feeling the pics they struck the value
of this draft so
no surprise there do we have any
questions or any other thoughts before
we get out of here greg
connor uh let me check the comments
because you know i love to give out
hoodies and so i can hop back in here
and i said i see gtg23
says who do you think the bears could
take in the second round who do you
think the bears can possibly grab in the
second round i also say i also see jojo
four seven three four five four says
connor any sleeper picks so we got
sleeper picks and maybe bears picks in
the second round um
yeah connor do you have a sleeper for
the first round
any sleep so let's let's start with the
bears right there and we'll talk
offensive line here greg you're thinking
max mitchell is somebody that falls into
that range some of these guys that went
in the end of round one of my mock draft
could fall to the bears ryman is in that
range i think penning is in that range i
don't think canard makes it there so the
bears are looking to improve their
offensive line and i think there are
valuable offensive line players there in
early round two now when you're looking
at sleepers for round one the
conversation always starts with the
quarterbacks and this is an uninspiring
group but they interview well at the
combine they'd be impressing private
workouts throwing the ball you're going
to have desmond ritter sam howell those
kind of players maybe enter the round
one conversation so never doubt the
quarterbacks surge into round one every
single year that conversation starts up
right after the combine as these teams
get to spend times with guys
and one more that has a chance although
i think the testing will keep him out of
round one as great as he was in mobile
alabama is trey mcbride the tight end
from colorado state he's got maybe the
best hands in this draft very productive
at the position a lot of college tight
ends do not produce at a high level he
was the focal point of their offense so
if one of these teams on the back end
uh likes him enough or a team from round
two is worried about him falling could
trade back into the end of round one to
go get trey mcbride so the quarterbacks
and mcbride are the sleepers i would
keep an eye on right now
watch out for those sleepers connor i
got one more for you one more and this
is it
j
b
j b a j e t j e t says could the bucks
take a quarterback in this year's draft
it's a great one it's a great question
from a jba jet right there
i'm gonna say no and yeah could they but
that's not their plan right now i think
they they look at the roster they've
made greg they have a guy there in bruce
arians that is is not going to be
coaching for the next 10 years there is
a chance that todd balls and byron
leftwich who took interviews this year
do move on in the near future for head
coaching opportunities i think if they
can't talk tom brady into coming back
they try to go the tom brady route again
can you go get a russell wilson what
does that cost you're not going to get
aaron rodgers that's not going to happen
but can you go get a russell wilson and
if you strike out in the veteran
quarterback market
you're not going into next year with
kyle trask as your starter okay nobody's
gonna be doing that so
then you look at their selection there
where they're picking in the back end of
round one and it goes into the two guys
i just warned you about sam howell and
desmond ritter malik willis will be gone
kenny pickett will be gone i think matt
corral will be gone can ritter make it
there can howl make it there they
certainly certainly can so that's not
the bucks plan a i don't even think it's
the bucks plan b but if all else fails
and they're looking at the draft at plan
c and they don't have a quarterback then
that conversation comes into play
gotcha gotcha hey shout out to everybody
that i mentioned jba jet you're walking
away with a br grid iron hoodie but uh
yeah it was fun man shout out to
everybody that walked away with hoodies
that's a wrap so thank you to all the
comments they were jumping thank you to
greg who joined me here and relayed the
messages gave out hoodies give out a lot
of hoodies today uh this comment section
deserved it the reception was awesome i
love the thoughts on the pics you liked
i like the thoughts on the pics you
didn't like that's why we want your
voice here because we can look how to do
it differently next time or not we'll
see how it goes but thank you so much
everyone the super bowl a post super
bowl mock draft in the books this will
not be the last one so stay tuned for
after the nfl comment follow along in
the bleacher report app follow along on
br gridiron for greg ivory i'm connor
rogers we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you